emmy piece began this week's mini
plenary session in Brussels with a
tribute to and minute silence for the
murdered British MP joe cox the victims
of the orlando terror killings and for
the two french police officers killed
near paris draw unemployment was near
the island and authorities ish cfa
unlamented I'm visits that in a later
debate mep s argued more must be done to
fight radicalization and hatred directed
at groups including the increasing
radicalization of lone wolves via the
internet a rare appearance by the
Israeli and Palestinian presidents but
not together it was a day apart but in
the same chamber email open manana Lucia
mish ago game console TV behati rallies
dear at ed Ave Sheila him money gear
Lima Kavita Muhammad seen by a result
DVD up with Nia Sablin appreciative
Shelia hacer moon faith and LBJ afifa
love seeing and a blatant inhale
photography SATA cool before c1 a severe
alien meanwhile at the special tax to
committee any peace focused on an issue
of rising concern to citizens tax
avoidance they passed a report to be
voted at full plenary later calling for
among other things a tax havens
blacklist sanctions against
non-cooperative tax jurisdictions and a
code of conduct for banks and tax
advisers 28 member states but many more
flavors and gastronomy is to save her
during an open tasting inside the
Parliament encapsulating the spirit of
adventure and experimentation Bon
Appetit it seems to become